let's start with uh what's happening in
switzerland so luongo switzerland made
bitcoin legal tender yesterday we all
know this has already happened in el
salvador and there's been a bunch of
other countries that have said this may
be happening soon luango is a city in
switzerland there it is we've got a
pompliano tweeting that out right there
with the bitcoin
i don't know who that is but he's got
some uh some decent tweets that's my big
bro oh you know him yeah i know him and
great tweet there great legal tender uh
yeah side note he needs to take that
tornado out of his name but
we'll leave it at that uh second off
yeah so luango uh it's a smaller city in
switzerland i believe it's you know a
top 10 largest city or something like
that maybe 65 or 70 000 people live
there so it's small on the general scale
of kind of the total adoption of bitcoin
but it's certainly a step in the right
direction they have been very very very
very bitcoin friendly this specific city
uh they've been working with a bunch of
different merchants to onboard customers
and make sure people can pay with it as
legal tender uh now all the merchants in
the city have to accept bitcoin as legal
tender so there's gonna be a bunch of
onboarding of new people tourists all
this kind of stuff so i think this is
really good uh it's similar to what
we've seen in el salvador and el
salvador is quickly becoming the
blueprint for this stuff right because
whether you want to say that it's the
right move or it's not the right move i
think we need to i think we can all
agree that it probably takes some time
to play out
but more so the stats that are really
impressive out of there are that more
people now have uh wallets digital
wallets and they had traditional bank
accounts right more than 50 of the
population in el salvador has it and if
el salvador was a technology company and
you were looking at it from an
investment perspective it would be a
high growth company because what they
are doing is they are strategically
using incentives to get people to
download these wallets they're offering
i think it was 30 at a time if you want
to open the wallet and when the minimum
wage is much lower than it is here in
the united states in el salvador that is
certainly more enticing than it would be
to someone here so people are going
they're opening up these wallets and
what happened was they got a bunch of
people millions of people to actually
download it within the first week or two
weeks and soon enough they had more
people with digital wallets than they
did bank accounts el salvador is all in
it looks like luango switzerland is next
and it'll be fascinating to see who
comes after that what do you think john
yeah i mean over four million people
have the chiva wallet app in el salvador
alone so over four million salvadorians
have the chivo wallet app which is key
it's a key number just to talk about
adoption within the nation itself since
making bitcoin legal tender in september
that is very very fast adoption you were
talking about it almost being like a
like a tech startup right well this tech
startup would require massive amounts of
fundraising uh just based off of the
customers that they've acquired in such
a short amount of time and then lugano
switzerland like you said it's the ninth
largest
city in switzerland it's a city of about
64 000 people look at this chart right
here right internet vs crypto adoption
this was uh i think the first time i
ever saw this was in
um
i believe it was coinbase's last
quarterly earnings report or something
like that but the this chart has gone
viral a few different times now and it's
so it's overlaying internet adoption
versus crypto adoption and what we've
seen is now
uh we're you know eight or nine or ten
years into this thing and it's still
mirroring from an internet perspective
and obviously we know today that the
internet has billions of users all
across the world uh it is one of the
most important technologies ever created
if not the most important technology
ever created and crypto is following
along that same adoption curve not to
mention that there are just as many
detractors as there were in the early
internet ages right so internet is this
technology now that everyone knows is
valuable no one would dare say it is not
valuable no one would say it is stupid
everyone knows that it is important it's
access to education it's access to
everything that the world uses today and
crypto is following along that same
adoption curve obviously there is an
inherent advantage when the internet
already exists and now people can go do
these wallets and everything else but
when you look at it strictly from a size
and scale standpoint it's super super
impressive to me it'll be interesting
too to see like we're at 2022 obviously
what happens in 2023 what happens in
2024 what happens if the price goes up a
lot right what we've seen traditionally
is when bitcoin goes up and we have
these massive bull runs uh the adoption
skyrockets and we see people come in not
only to download wallets they get in the
bitcoin network and the ecosystem but
they go into other cryptos also nfts are
a big portion of that right and uh
people come on every day
in the comments and other places on
twitter and they talk about nfts and and
i think majority of bitcoiners or at
least a large portion of bitcoiners
think it's stupid they're like this is
dumb you could do this in a million
different other ways it doesn't really
have any inherent value most of them are
just uh stupid drawings by kids there's
hundreds of pictures of of projects a
day now uh and there's just some a lot
of slosh going on right there's a lot of
money floating around but at the end of
the day it's driving adoption right and
look at the look here's another chart
right here of bitcoin on-chain users
versus other technologies internet users
up top mobile accounts paypal accounts
and then exchange users when it comes to
bitcoin and it's taken off at a much
faster trajectory for sure and at some
point obviously you know just just based
on the the size of growth right and the
compounding rate that you're able to do
this at and the number of people in the
world it slows down at some point but
just how quickly it has become a
mainstay right within culture within
finance within the world is incredible
to watch because
look it was uh you know
late 2000s 2009 where uh we we really
started looking a lot of this stuff and
then 2016 2017 where it became like a
global thing and people started to see
it on a scale so uh again it's going to
be interesting to see how these charts
pan out but it's super exciting to look
at right now yeah and i think the
internet um
the internet had a caveat that was it
was very expensive right to get a
computer back in the 80s and 90s so not
that many people were being on board and
i think they could have been onboard a
lot faster if they if the cost was down
and if they could see that the power of
the internet was only going to continue
and bitcoin has that ability um because
it's a very like call
cost of customer acquisition and it's
very very low right all you need is a
smartphone and an internet connection to
be able to plug into the bitcoin network
and utilize everything that bitcoin has
to offer so when you think about it like
that like bitcoin should be adopted
faster than the internet um and globally
i agree do we have the quote uh on el
salvador that we can pull up too
um so
yeah here's a quote right here by paulo
ardino uh we'll just assume that that's
correct he's the cto of tether he said
el salvador's gdp increased by 10 and
it's tourism by 30 after declaring
bitcoin a legal tender imagine what we
can do in a city at the center of europe
right and i think that that's important
to uh to distinguish because we've all
said this for for a long time now that
is bitcoin is good for business right
global people are coming from uh people
are coming from all across the globe to
visit el salvador now they're going to
bitcoin beach they're going to help
boots on the ground and get adoption
going because they know that they put
their foot down and they said hey look
we're going to be a bitcoin nation state
and if we can do that in switzerland if
you can do that in other european cities
if you can do that in other places
around the world you're going to see the
same exact things because bitcoin is
global there's literally people all
around the world working on this
non-stop 24 7. so ultimately what you're
going to find is that whatever cities
adopt this first they're going to see
the greatest benefits and then the
cities that follow along after that
we'll see diminishing returns but we'll
see what other european cities do it i
think it's exciting for switzerland it's
not the first time that they've been
talking about bitcoin right they're
they've already worked with hundreds of
merchants at this point to get them up
and running and accepting bitcoin uh but
it'll be interesting to see if
switzerland on a larger scale starts to
take a position in bitcoin if they start
to buy bitcoin if they start to do other
things from a regulatory standpoint to
attract people to work on bitcoin uh in
their region uh i i think the sky's the
limit right like switzerland is is small
relative to some of the other players
that could be doing things but the
people said the same exact stuff about
el salvador and i think it's made a huge
difference hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time